لكن ان كانت الحرب هديه لواشنطن بحسب مركز
تحليل السياسه الاوروبيه حيث يمكنها من
توفير المليارات بالمقارنه بمكانه ستنفقه
على ردع روسيا لكن هذه الحرب هي ماساه
لاوكرانيا حربا بدات في القرم قبل تسع
سنوات وستنتهي بها بحسب زنسكي القرم كانت
منصه عمليات روسيه عسكريه فهل لا تكون
الحرب النقمه ايضا على روسيا بينما اولته
وتبقى تحقيق كل اهدافها في اوكرانيا حسب
ما صرح بوتن اليوم فاولويتك حاليا
استعادته الشبه جزيره القرم واملها في ذلك
يستند الى التراجع الروسي مؤخرا وتحديدا
انسحاب من خلفه
سيطره الاوكرانيين على خرسون تضعوا شبه
جزيره القرم قابقه قوسين من نيران
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه لا سيما انظمه هاي
مارس وناس ماس فبعد استعاده خرسون اضرا
للجيش الروسي الى ابعاد مهابط الطائرات
المروحيه والطائرات دون طيار والاليات
والمعدات الثقيله من المنطقه كما زاد ذلك
من حماس الاوكرانيين لاستعاده كامل لاراضي
المقاطعه التي تفصل شبه الجزيره عن مناطق
سيطره الروس وقطع الامدادات عنها من
المناطق الانفصاليه وجعلها شبه محاصره الا
من جسر القرم في الوقت الذي يدعو الرئيس
الاوكراني حلفائه الغربيين على دعم قوته
التي تحقق تقدما كبيرا بسرعه المطلوبه حتى
لا تتسنى الفرصه لالتقاط انفسهم ويصف
دعوات التفاوض بمحاولاته لكسب الوقت
والاستعداد لمزيد من الاعمال العدائيه
ولاجل تحقيق هذا الامل لا فالقرمو هدف
الرئيسي للنار الاوكرانيه او بالاحرى
المسيرات وتحديدا سبيستون عاصمتها ومركز
اسطول البحر الاسود خرج رئيس مكتب زلسكي
اندريه
لامر بالغ الاهميه عمليات من عسكريه
محتمله
مطالبه الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا
بالواقعيه وهنا يطرح السؤال هل تستطيع
اكرانيا تنفيذ ذلك بمساعده الغربيه من
وجهه نظر رئيسي لجنه الدفاع والامن في
البرلمان الروسي
كيف لا تملكه الموارد اول القوه اللازمه
اخيرا نقطه اتفاقنا روسيا امريكي
عايزين